wait what was the thought I had I'm so
sorry mark
what's going on reject nation i'm greg
alba i'm movie man mark movie man mark
check out his youtube channel people
wide variety of comedy I'm telling you
that's worth it
hey we're gonna watch today from Jimmy
Kimmel mean tweets hip-hop edition some
real gangsta [ __ ] videos get hell of use
oh yeah seven minutes we can get a
fraction of that yeah I think we could
move on we could get seventy views real
quick I wanna give a patron of déjà to a
man named Scuba Steve Scuba Steve I've
talked about him before I want to shout
him out specifically him today
because he actually has an Instagram
page where he does all kinds of awesome
graffiti art worth check it out right
here it's highly illegal
so who more gangster - shout out on this
hip-hop related video than Scuba Steve
and by the way dude I hope to see you on
tinder soon because you are one sexy
mofo who should be getting all them
[ __ ] or guys whichever way you swim I
mean Scuba Steve doesn't sound too much
like a gangster name but I'll believe
you if you tell me that he's gangster I
mean the only thing is I VD is the
gangster part yeah but is there any
scuba egg involved in his Instagram I
don't know why he's called I don't know
no one called Little John well that's
pretty self-explanatory though he's he's
little or he's big but he's going by the
irony of it I'm doing the opposite I
thought was pretty self-explanatory but
what is the opposite of scuba walk we're
really too much into this
[Applause]
[ __ ] it needs to be kicked in the boss
I don't think anyone deserves to be
kicked in the balls
I think you should take these violent
thoughts and place your energy somewhere
a little more productive is that rocky
and load of bull Yong next why
everybody's entitled to their own pants
I'm not really mad at that now that at
the real Eve is all post-racial and
trying to raise colorblind babies does
she still have those paw prints on her a
toddler ex-con or push your tea if
you're still rocking Bray's this year
yeah I still have my braids they're
never going anywhere and they're not
gonna grow it's fine just when you think
maybe the world is gonna be okay big
Shana comes out with a new piece of song
like she can't rap on beat to save her
life
Britney MA also physically fights people
that talk I wish I could make music like
racing we're gonna make millions of
dollars for it
focus on getting a fat ass and shade guy
you can inspire people to be great when
you haven't seen you did that power
takes it that's what trippy red looks
like bloody 1 2 talent whatsoever
aquafina has the voice of a 58 year old
divorce attorney thank I know logic is
the worst rapper of all time Paula Deen
can rap better yeah that's me instead
looks like liquorice and his teeth looks
like M&Ms he looks like a complete [ __ ]
I just farted and it smells like Wally's
entire discography must be eating curry
goat Todd outline looks like the crapper
Melania do it
Lil Wayne is what happens when you pour
for local on a grim
[Music]
[Laughter]
I see what he was the last one they
always have the one you know hip-hop
artists they handle it so much better
than everyone else who does these mean
tweets yeah you noticed that yeah sorry
because you're in hip-hop we're talking
[ __ ] yeah so for them to be getting
these tweets that honestly don't seem as
intense as like other celebrities I'm
sure this sounds like nothing to them
yeah actors and stuff and so sheltered
you know their entirety or whatever so
it breaks their heart too bad they don't
give an Oscar for blowing ass this is
Matt Damon win every year I mean other
musicians and other types of celebrities
that I've seen on the mean tweets you
always see a mixture we're like one or
two of them is like whoa I can't believe
that was yeah oh my god I'm offended you
always see a variety of that this one
everyone's just like yeah yeah chill
about it yeah you know like my music try
maybe exactly it was kind of refreshing
to just see that kind of perspective and
attitude on getting these tweets so
sometimes I'm comforted by watching
celebrities get upset by choices like
okay so sometimes you guys do get upset
I know what it's like yeah but then to
see these guys so Amir did what three
and sometimes I wonder if like the
writers of Jimmy Kimmel Live make those
tweets I think they do yeah these reload
you make them up to be especially you
didn't give you stream after you can
find that or they're just all completely
made up it could be they have a research
team that looks for these tweets yeah
but at the same time it's like how do
you look out with such good some of them
seem kind of like fake yeah it's like
someone really gonna just have that
thought and ripe in this guy's head
looks like licorice I mean I feel like
it's an entire writers room like how can
we really get this guy and they have
like a picture of the guy and a group
rappers their appearance is so vibrant
and it's super easy to target them yeah
a lot of them were about appearance what
the appearance or music that's about
I mean it's the most you can really do
but either way they seem so chill about
it I'm also thinking to myself that they
probably read multiple tweets - yeah you
could always see them look back down
like they're about to read another one
okay so choose the best way so maybe
they have like a variety of real ones
and then the one that gets the best
reaction is the one that they'll stick
with because a lot of what makes the
tweets funny is hey how the celebrity
reads them and B how the celebrity
reacts upon reading they choose the
meanest tweet
yeah they choose the meanest one on the
bottom of the best reactions as well
either way I think it's a brilliant
segment we're gonna say this is the
first hip-hop edition is it it like
numbers that many say no it just says
hip-hop additions so it's the first two
might be that we're still finding new
like ideas yeah it's pretty neat and
especially for someone like 50 cent to
be getting this who came up in like the
gangster rap kind of music he's getting
this tweet he just goes on an actual let
me process what you're saying and why
this doesn't make sense and why this is
not a good thing for you to be saying to
someone yeah I also think it's ironic
how we were talking about weird names
like super Steve and we go into a
segment where they only have weird names
like none of these guys use their real
name exactly hooba Steve could have
easily been on that's my point yes see
full circle yeah so maybe scuba-dive
it's open your eyes
maybe another rapper too maybe it'd be a
good one sometimes there's no real
explanation as to why they have these
names like 50 cent why is he 50 cent
like is the gap in his teeth can it hold
50 Cent's is that why this would have
been just a little bit better if they
had managed to get Eminem in here yeah
maybe he's the sensitive one they filmed
this segment he cried and he said to his
people that this can never be on there
yeah either way this is a fun time
anyway guys yeah thanks for watching you
didn't subscribe to the reject nation
click the notification bell and hey
check out movie man mark on his YouTube
channel check it immediately I am
subscribed so you should subscribe to
people that'd be great
thanks for being here Marcus no problem
trying to get to 10k so we'll see what
happens I'm like two hundred and fifty
away maybe we can get you an extra five
more subscribers Oh that'd be great I'd
be two hundred and forty five away then
that is